Oi e aí galera que assiste meu canal
tudo bom com vocês esse é o segundo
vídeo eu nem acredito que a gente tá
dando continuidade alguma coisa bem mais
do que um por cento a gente vai dar
almoçado e já já ir para o teatro eu
chego no teatro do show muitas horas
antes tá então Robson pede olic para
galera aí deixa o like se inscreve no
canal e se você não deixar o like clica
aí também não na comentário deixe o
comentário que você boca gente não
motivo uma tinta porque não
tem nenhuma Sininho parte tentar sente o
servidor e não vai falar se no Sininho
assim no Sininho comenta no Gostei pode
clicar no comentário em obra
e um arrozinho branco de umas mais
eu
vou comer
[Aplausos]
você perdeu Achei você tava te esperando
porque eu não consigo dormir sozinho
nossa você vai falar esse lá todo mundo
mesmo Pode mas tem que preciso saber
Manoel As pessoas sempre falam que você
tem um alcance muito grande chegar aí
pessoas que é verdade
[Risadas]
alimentares agora nós vamos para o
Teatro sempre chego cedo por quê o som
aí tem os cartões certo que se chow-chow
de teste eu vejo essas piadas boas não é
preciso for boa não conto mais nada
muito essa galera é muito e pouco é
porque eu fui pronto eu aviso a posição
de câncer a piada para ver rir mais
trocar a palavra
canal passou três deixou
desse jeito próximo vai ser do mesmo
jeito
hoje é o dia da mentira
eu brinquei você é
é
muito gostosa de brincar com você está
tudo papai Se você morrer eu sei falar
com você mas não é
[Música]
ah
ah ah
E aí
e
nem mulher comeu uma disquinhos nem anos
lactobacilos vivos
e as fotos de som aberto e
chega não passar estamos indo agora para
o Teatro Via Sul e deitar-me resumir
empresário extraordinário chique é
legais para o Teatro Não esqueça de Jair
clicando em gostei aí tá bom
porque está o segundo vídeo amanhã bom
já que você tá vendo que esse ali em
cima tem hashtag dois que no caso é o
dia dois sem então sabe que tem um dia
um então se você se já tive Pode ser que
já deu três quando você tá assistindo
dois então não esqueça de assistir todos
os dias porque o interessante ia pegar a
rotina inteira pegar um dia só que ali
não tem graça
não é o meu pretinho não faz não vai dar
passando
E aí meu patrão forte e
é
isso amor tá bom
a mulher que eu digo
Oi Adilson a
E aí
o que foi que ele sabe era para eu
liberar do Índio ele parte do projeto de
longe homem homem luz e o Forró lá
quando levamos pirata Pirata desde
segunda música do vídeo olha aí ó
[Música]
E aí
Oi
[Música]
meu amor
minha mãe
aquela
hora até aqui
[Música]
gatinho
chegou a
o clima
E aí
ó ó
mulher hoje é o primeiro show de uma
série de
25 25 não 23 23 23 anos que a gente vai
fazer aqui em Fortaleza Ceará que
comer agora quando eu chegar eu lhe
respondi assim eu fiquei assim ó ajudado
a
o
direto outra coisa que ele sabe que eu
gosto vídeo de assaltante que se esconde
mal e
E aí
Oi gente botou né
levanta a cabeça és assim ó
E aí
[Música]
e
também já pode ir para Disney 1
o
[Música]
deixou pai é
oi oi
e não é que o Bruno os cachorrão chegou
a hora que você é
E
ai que vida ai que vida ai que vida boa
vida boa é essa tudo junto ai
falando de Itacaré saindo da escola
agora né 10 a 15 anos vai tava lá eu me
mais orgulho de dizer isso tem mais
pirateadas de 2012 com mais gravidade E
trocou de leite mais importante viu mas
download que tem que dormir 95 aí 22
milhões download 2011 download tá aí na
tua cara otário
eu amei ter um show rir e fiquei com o
WhatsApp preparado para receber o
Pokémon
eu cai agora
11 anos 11 anos diz assim às vezes dá
vontade de ir em Fortal
e você
o
exame top 1
é
mais um para colocar primeiro na verdade
né Portal
já tá aqui ó
o link
Oi
bom dia rapaziada segundo dia do show
hoje bola aí já tá comendo seu belo pão
de queijo aí é para quem pode né não é
para quem quer agora quem quiser curtir
aí obrigado Senhor te abençoe
aí eu amar a vai cortar tá ligado o
Aniel já chegou o olhando não o Amaral
já chegou e ele se fosse parece né né
estrutura estrutura
o amarelo já vem buscar a câmera que
agora ele vai é de tá esse blog aqui né
que eu fiz ali nos momentos de show você
está assistindo agora o segundo o que
existe o primeiro então se você não
assistiu o primeiro assista Só existe o
segundo por causa do primeiro se não
seria primeiro não desse então ele vai
levar o cartão aqui agora e a partir de
agora eu vou começar a gravar o de
amanhã então amanhã volte aqui nesse
mesmo horário nesse mesmo canal que vai
dar tudo certinho dependendo desse rapaz
vou ter que ajeitar direito dessa vez
não sai de madrugada não foi culpa dele
eu gravei na hora certa eu mandei para
ele demorou Nossa Windows muito legal se
não gostar eh se esse tipo de conteúdo
esse tipo de parte aqui a gente dá maior
valor isso aqui faça mais isso aí eu vou
fazer para ficar com ela vem mais legal
eu poder entreter 30 dias porque não tem
quem aguente até o Big Brother tinha vez
passar 15 dias que você não verdade
diferente eu posso dormir na hora que
era o Tiago Abravanel meditando você
assistir às vezes 7:00 disso mas eu não
quero que seja assim aqui eu quero que
seja nossa dinâmica clique em gostei
tamo junto amanhã tem mais assistir o
primeiro e a nós vamos fazer e é para
troquinha do W vem vem Raven haypa
faz o w el rap del rap